Patrick, you and I did this show a very long time ago.
You're an original gangster of this show.
Yes.
That's right.
Totally.
You know, I was wondering what you were going to wear,
but my goodness, do you just deliver.
Ah, thank you, I'm so excited to be here.
It's funny, I think a lot of us got the memo on like,
"Hey, let's throw some color at this weather."
Yes.
You know?
Let's boost our mood.
I mean, you are really crushing it right now.
How does it feel?
I mean, it's just crazy.
I have a few billboards out right now,
my beauty brand, One Size, and I just feel so loved,
and for you to even have me on here is such a huge honor.
It's just crazy, I'm so excited.
I mean, you've worked with some beautiful,
extraordinary, famous faces.
Is there somebody that you haven't worked with
or are going to work with that you're excited about?
Well, I've always wanted to work with Oprah, mother O,
and paint her.
Or just have a chat with her.
But I mean, here today while I have a celebrity.
I would love to be lucky enough to get my makeup done
by you, that would be such an honor for me.
Thank you, I'm such a huge fan of you.
We actually FaceTimed when I did ET for Halloween
and you jumped on FaceTime with us.
I won't forget.
And I was like,
"Is Drew Barrymore gonna really answer our call?"
Absolutely.
It was just me and my brother
And I was like, "Is she gonna answer?"
Absolutely, I love to play, and I love what you do
because I feel like I've grown up in a makeup chair
and a hair and makeup trailer my whole life,
and I really feel like I got some really important messaging
on what beauty is, and to me, it was always about
these women and men who walked in early in the morning,
or, you know just kind of like furled in,
and through the transformation of hair and makeup
they would. (Patrick laughs)
And they would walk out different.
(crowd cheers)
(applause)
As an impressionable young child,
I was like, "That's what beauty is."
It's an empowerment,
it's something that happens on the inside.
It's a feeling and it's an empowerment.
So, we have your products here
which I'm really excited about.
How did you come up with the name One Size?
I was told to not be myself my whole life growing up.
I even went to work and I was asked to take off my makeup
by my manager.
And I remember a year later and I was shopping
and I couldn't fit any clothes in the store.
And I said, "You know what?
I can't buy anything here, but you know what?
I can buy makeup, because makeup is a one size fits all."
So being a man in makeup, I coined the, you know,
I used that as our tagline,
and One Size Beauty represents everyone,
and everywhere I go I try to wear as much red
to represent love, not just for each other,
but for yourself, and I feel like more than ever
self love is the hardest thing.
It is.
It is the hardest thing.
Now, your parents are here.
Yes.
They're here. (laughs)
(crowd cheering)
(applause)
Hi mom, hi dad.
Of course, the lady in the pink trench
who I commented on the second I came out here.
How fitting you are Patrick's mom?
Yeah, that's my dad, that's mama Star and papa Star.
How are you?
I'm well, thank you.
We're so excited.
First, we love you.
Oh, I love you guys, and I love your son so very much.
Thank you.
What was Patrick like as a kid, may I ask?
He was very graceful, loving, nurturing,
and very creative.
And, is it true that you share makeup tips with your mom?
I mean, she shares all of my makeup, my clothes.
I think that's mine, by the way. (laughs)
(crowd applauds)
She's learned everything under the sun,
and I've learned a lot from them
in terms of how to love yourself, embracing culture,
loving others, but I think they've learned
a tip or two for beauty.
I was wondering, as a father, how are you, pride-wise?
What was Patrick like in your eyes as a child?
We love him so much.
We're so proud of everything that he's doing for everybody,
not only for us.
That is such a beautiful gift.
It really is.
I'm not gonna take this moment for granted because,
you know, I just think it's a gift
if you get to have that kind of dialogue
and energy with your parents.
Let's never take this for granted, it's so beautiful.
(applause)
I think it's important to use social media
as a stage and a platform.
And at first I was like, "I'm not gonna show
my Filipino parents on social media."
But then I think once people saw or heard languages
in the back that resonated with them
or saw food and culture,
I think that's why I've amassed millions of views
because we've been able to leverage something so different
that not many LGBTQ kids can have.
So by showing them they find refuge
and comfort in viewing my channel
and viewing happiness and seeing the energy
and the dynamic that we have is just so special
that people are able to see that in us.
Also, you have so much to teach as a family.
You know, I mean, whether it's about love
or it's about mad skills,
and you have mad skills.
Oh, thank you.
(upbeat music)